I mean well we're in we're in business
to go out of business but you know so
long as we see stats that said it's
easier for a white man with a criminal
record to find a job in the black man
with that one we're in business for a
long time both frankly for that black
man and for the white guy who's being
treated almost as bad as the black
in the 21st century like the centuries
before there is a problem so big in this
society that you can see it from space
we think about the 18th century the 19th
century the 20th century the beginning
of any of those you know you would have
seen in the 18th century for instance
the transatlantic slave trade trade you
would have seen from space in the 19th
century the plantations across the south
with bodies been over closely together
working the fields you have seen in the
20th century the racial segregation you
know that literally no west of charles
street baltimore were black folks and
east of Charles were white folk and you
would see in this century the prisons
that pockmark our country our people in
our country are five percent of the
world's people and twenty-five percent
of the world's prisoners now what that
means and that's your people of all
colors if you took black and brown
people oh how to prison tomorrow this
country would still have way more than
its share of prisoners it would just be
by a factor of two and not a factor of
five so you know in our lifetime in my
lifetime uh this country has has great
as greatly increased the rate of widget
incarcerates white people and yet black
people are inc are incarcerated five
times more than that um you know and
that really defines at the beginning of
the century what we have to fix now in
order to bring down the incarceration
rate well you got to start with the
beginning of life make sure that parents
and schools are prepared to prepare
young people for success you gotta deal
with you know then the next stage of
life you're going to make sure that
people in this opportunity had the
opportunity to work at a good job they
have access to good health care and that
they have the opportunity to to build
wealth and to actually advance their
family's status in the country over time
and then finally we need to make sure
that our justice system works for the
interests of everybody that it that it
makes every community safer that we use
his incarceration as a last resort for
people our danger to themselves or just
society and now and that we use quite
frankly the the means that are allow us
to hold as much of our resources
for other priorities as possible mean
right now for instance you know New York
State last year we pushed them to change
the Rockefeller drug laws and they did
and in doing so not only were poor drug
addicts now given access to what rich
drug addicts always have access to which
is rehab but they saved a lot of money
in the process and that is sort of the
thing about the incarceration struggle
in our society is that it really at the
end of the day is the both the proof of
the failure of so many other strategies
education strategies employment
strategies it also is the acid that eats
away at each of those strategies state
of California right now UC system the
tuition rates going up thirty percent in
the fall there's no way to explain that
without acknowledging that California is
one of five states that spends more on
incarceration than public education if
you look at the pattern over the last 25
years literally the priorities have
flipped um state spending in California
on public higher education has gone from
about twelve percent the budget to run
four or five percent and at the same
time state spending in California on
incarceration was going from four or
five percent the budget to around eleven
or twelve percent and you see that
across the country that as as what we
spend on conservation goes up the mind
we have for schools and colleges goes
down and so part of the struggle for our
generation is allowing people to see the
connection and to understand that the
end the day this isn't a movement for
education over here and a movement for
workers rights over there and a movement
for you know justice reform is all one
broad domestic human rights movement I
think that's the biggest functional
struggle is to get people to see the
connections and then to connect
themselves to one another